et rapatriés en Corée du Nord,
où ils sont torturés, emprisonnés
ou publiquement exécutés.
Même si j'ai été eu la chance de sortir,
beaucoup de nord-coréens n'ont pas eu cette chance.
C'est tragique que les nord-coréens aient à cacher leurs identités
et affronter tant de choses seulement pour survivre.
Même après avoir appris une langue nouvelle et avoir trouvé un travail,
leur monde peut être bouleversé en un instant.
Voilà pourquoi, après avoir caché mon identité pendant 10 ans,
j'ai décidé de prendre le risque d'aller en Corée du Sud,
j'ai commencé une nouvelle vie, encore une fois.
M'installer en Corée du Sud était plus dur
que ce que je ne pensais.
L'Anglais était tellement important en Corée du Sud,
donc j'ai dû commencé à apprendre ma 3ème langue.
Aussi, j'ai réalisé qu'il y avait une grande différence
entre le Nord et le Sud.
On est tous coréens, mais à l’intérieur,
nous sommes devenus très différents
à cause de 67 ans de division.
Je suis même passée par une crise d'identité.
Suis-je sud-coréenne ou nord-coréenne ?
D'où suis-je ? Qui suis-je ?
Soudain, il n'y avait plus de pays
dont je puisse fièrement dire qu'il était le mien.
Mais si l'ajustement au style de vie de la Corée du Sud n'était pas facile,
j'avais un plan.
J'ai commencé à étudier pour les examens d'entrée à l'université.
Alors que je commençais à m'habituer à ma nouvelle vie,
j'ai reçu un appel téléphonique désastreux.
Les autorités nord-coréennes
ont intercepté de l'argent que j'envoyais à ma famille,
et, comme punition, ma famille allait
être emmenée de force
vers un endroit perdu dans les campagnes.
Ils devaient sortir vite,
alors j'ai commencé à préparer un plan pour les aider à s'échapper.
Les nord-coréens doivent voyager d'incroyables distances
sur le chemin de la liberté.
Il est presque impossible de passer la frontière
entre la Corée du Nord et la Corée du Sud,
donc, ironiquement, j'ai pris un vol de retour en Chine
et je me suis dirigée vers la frontière avec la Corée du Nord.
Comme ma famille ne parlait pas Chinois,
j'ai dû les guider,
à travers plus de 3200 kilomètres en Chine
et ensuite en Asie du sud-est.
Le voyage en bus a pris une semaine,
et on a failli se faire prendre plusieurs fois.
Une fois, notre bus fût arrêté
et un officier de la police chinoise monta à bord.
Il prit les papiers de tout le monde,
et commença à les questionner.
Comme ma famille ne comprenait pas le chinois,
je pensais qu'ils allaient se faire arrêter.
Alors que l'officier s'approcha de ma famille,
je me levai brusquement et lui dis
qu'ils étaient sourds et muets
et que j'étais leur chaperonne.
Il me regarda d'un air suspect,
mais par chance, il m'a cru.
Nous avons fait tout le chemin jusqu'à la frontière avec le Laos,
mais j'ai dû dépensé presque tout mon argent
en pots de vins pour les douanes au Laos.
Mais même après avoir passé la frontière,
ma famille a été arrêtée et mise en prison
pour être rentré illégalement.
Après avoir payé l'amende et le pot de vin,
ma famille fut relâchée après un mois,
mais peu après, elle s'est encore fait arrêtée et emprisonnée
dans la capitale du Laos.
Ce fut l'un des moments les plus bas de ma vie.
J'avais tout fait pour mener ma famille vers la liberté,
et on en était si proche,
mais ma famille fu jetée en prison
à deux pas de l’ambassade de Corée du Sud.
Je faisais des allers-retours entre le bureau d'immigration
et le poste de police,
essayant désespérément de faire libérer ma famille,
mais je n'avais plus assez d'argent
pour payer un pot de vin à qui que ce soit.
J'ai perdu tout espoir.
À ce moment là, j'ai entendu la voix d'un homme me demander,
« Qu'est-ce qui ne va pas ? »
J'étais tellement surprise
qu'un étranger puisse s’intéresser assez pour me poser la question.
Avec mon pauvre Anglais, et avec un dictionnaire,
je lui ai expliqué la situation, et sans hésitation,
l'homme s'est dirigé vers un distributeur automatique
et à versé le reste de l'argent pour ma famille
et deux autres nord-coréens pour les libérer de prison.
Je l'ai remercié de tout mon cœur, et lui ai demandé,
« Pourquoi m'aidez-vous ? »
« Je ne t'aide pas », dit-il.
« J'aide le peuple de Corée du Nord. »
À ce moment là, j'ai pris conscience que c'était un moment symbolique dans ma vie.
Ce généreux étranger symbolisait un nouvel espoir pour moi
et le peuple de Corée du Nord alors que nous en avions tellement besoin,
et m'a montré que la générosité des étrangers
et le soutien de la communauté internationale
sont vraiment les rayons d'espoir dont nous, les nord-coréens, avons besoin.
Finalement, après notre long voyage,
ma famille et moi même étions réunis en Corée du Sud,
mais la liberté n'est que la moitié de la bataille.
Beaucoup de nord-coréens sont séparés de leurs familles,
et quand ils arrivent dans un nouveau pays,
ils débutent avec peu voire pas d'argent.
Alors nous pouvons bénéficier de la communauté internationale
pour l'éducation, l'apprentissage de l'anglais,
les formations professionnelles, et d'autres encore.
Nous pouvons également servir de pont
entre les gens en Corée du Nord
et le monde extérieur,
car beaucoup d'entre nous restent en contact
avec de la famille toujours à l’intérieur,
et nous envoyons des informations et de l'argent
qui aident à changer la Corée du Nord de l'intérieur.
J'ai été tellement chanceuse, reçu tellement d'aide
et d'inspiration dans ma vie,
que je veux donner aux aspirants nord-coréens
une chance de prospérer
avec le soutien international.
Je suis confiante que vous verrez de plus en plus
de nord-coréens réussir partout dans le monde,
même sur la scène de TED.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)